[Music]
foreign
a first look at what is on the front
pages time to see what's making the
headlines with the Guardians Deputy
political editor Jessica elgot and Harry
Cole the political editor at the sun
welcome to both of you as ever let's
check out the front pages shall we
starting with the I which leads on the
Prime Minister facing a formal inquiry
by parliament's commissioner for
standards following allegations that he
may have failed to declare the shares
his wife holds in a childcare agency
that was given a boost in the budget
that's true is also on the front page of
the Metro the headline surely some
mistake pm and on the front of the
Guardian which also reports on energy
suppliers agreeing to a ban on forcibly
installing prepayment meters in the
homes of customers over the age of 85.
the financial times reports on the
Russian opposition activist Vladimir
kalamaza being sentenced to 25 years in
prison that's the picture story at least
at the top
The Daily Mirror leads on the father of
Stephen Lawrence oh that's the Daily
Express to apologize reasons to be
cheerful the economy is on the mend the
paper tells us
foreign
confess or never go free Neville
Lawrence's warning
Andy star has the headline to boldly go
where no visually challenged man has
gone before reporting that a lack of
gravity causes eyesight problems for
astronauts
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
or our guests so let's head straight to
Jessica elgot and Harry Cole and uh
kicking off Harry with the sunach under
investigation story making the lead of a
number of newspapers what's his defense
what's the claim um what about what
happens now
well you remember in October when it was
that Russia's next stood on the steps
Downing Street said there'd be a new
broom accountability transparency at
every level yet six months later he
hasn't published the ministerial list of
interests which he claims he did declare
all of his wife's business uh links in
now they've been kicking themselves in
Downing Street tonight a little bit I
think because they've tripped up here I
don't think this is exactly Watergate I
don't think this is exactly gonna read I
don't think anyone really thinks uh not
least generator MP not these labor MPS
not even the people probably who
reported which is enact over this that
his wife is you know on the take that
you know he's in in politics to make
lots of money they have zunax have an
incredible amount of wealth but this
just does feed into a slightly hubristic
I'd say attitude that number 10 seemed
to have once again to basic rules now uh
Michigan when he was before MPS
um just uh last month basically was
talking about this child care company
child care companies they were going to
get um additional money
um thanks to the budget to to help try
and recruit more child minders into a
struggling industry now at that time he
was given the opportunity by labor MP
who knew exactly what she was doing
Catherine mckinnell who said do you want
to tell us anything by the way anything
you want to get off your chest about
child care companies and a slightly
nervous suit neck laughed and said oh um
you know what all my declarations are
declared in the usual way now yes number
10 are saying they detected The Cabin
numbers but he hasn't declared it to
Parliament now it's a bit of a gray area
about what you're meant to declare to
Parliament your own financial interest
as an MP yes but you should you declare
interest of your spouse number 10 is
saying well no that is not relevant it's
only interested is only relevant to his
interest as a minister but an
unfortunate predicament for the man who
promised to be a new broom to be again
under investigation not long after again
another slip up with a seat belt where
you've got another fine and he was
caught the other day not walking his dog
with a lead in the park and just saying
if you're gonna promise to be Mr rules
and Mr transparency Mr accountability
you've got to get the basics right and
it's a bit of a bit of an own goal here
yes you say itself high standards the
trip up is quicker to be fair um yeah
but I I guess there's all sorts of
elements about this you know has she got
a stake in the company that he should
have known about is it part of a fund
you know all of this sort of stuff
um but the uh the Metro with a bit of a
play on the maths push that he had today
surely some mistake PM um sunic
announces plans to make all children
learn maths and then he investigates
over a failure to declare wife's shares
so they're quite enjoying the
juxtaposition of these two
yeah and on all of it and as Harry said
just comes across as a bit hapless you
know it's a prime minister who was uh
fined by the police for turning up a bit
early to to uh to a party
um during covid
um which he was never really meant to be
at the first place and fined for not
wearing a seat belt which he posted
himself in on on a video so you know I
think this as well feels like something
that could have been avoided quite
easily you know if the decorations had
been done in a timely way
um number 10 will say that the you know
that the Declarations should only
generally be made once or twice a year
but we've had you know three prime
ministers in the last year a lot of
different ministerial posts so you'd
expect it to have been done a lot sooner
than it has done and and you know the
the only way that we can know about
these these things and these interests
is is if if people declare them and and
therefore it's transparent that's the
whole purpose of it
um I mean soon like today was really
kind of trying to move the agenda onto
something a lot more kind of long-term
ambitious talking about extend ending
maths to 18 and even that felt a bit
flailing it felt like
um you know he he wasn't exactly sure
how it was going to shake out that that
these um this maths to 18 you know
whether it's going to be a qualification
whether that's going to mean
um people doing it sort of exams in pure
maths or whether it's just going to mean
working out how to do your tax return
um he you had to admit that obviously
the UK would need a lot more Math
teachers if you know in order to fulfill
the ambition and you know it gave the
speech at uh at a school in in Islington
and uh only one of the students there
was wanted to ask him a question about
it um and before you know there was
there was a few more awkward questions
on math teaching from from journalists
and and then on to the strikes so it
hasn't been the best day all round for
for Rishi neck yes and probably
legitimately people saying why aren't
you prioritizing strikes including
tracking teachers rather than these
long-term aims which no one else seems
that fussed about
um but but on the other the matter labor
sniffing an opening here because wealth
during a cost of living crisis equals uh
they think in voters Minds being out of
touch and and that will also always be
the problem for issue soon that won't
hurt
um yes and and no actually there's been
interesting focus groups uh and polling
that's been floating around the last few
weeks actually that actually amongst
undecided voters that actually because
it's sort of counter counter sort of
narrative because he is so rich and
because his wife is so rich that
actually
um people think that sunax in the game
for the right reasons you wouldn't think
that would be the public reaction but
that seems to be sort of shining through
a little bit in in some polling and some
focus groups now laborer determined to
paint him as out of touch they think
they've got an open goal is the guy that
wears the Gucci loafers to a building
site you know he's the guy that fills up
his 600 liter million liter whatever it
was swimming pool
um just days you know before a hose pipe
band they're desperately desperately
trying to paint him as his out of touch
um sort of billionaire Global elitist
you know Green Card holding non-dom
marrying sort of uh yeah Tory tough back
to those days they have to be quite
careful with that because it's not
necessarily that clear-cut but it's
local election season we're now perhaps
14 months away from a general election
maybe even sooner than that if if the
economy continues to pick up at pace so
you know you can see the the dividing
line starting to be drawn but it's not
always that black and white actually
what's really interesting and we we
speak to our readers a lot
um we we the sun readers are polled with
an inch of their life often to find out
what the nation is really thinking and
actually the first thing that people say
about Rishi sulak often it isn't he's a
millionaire he's out of touch it's
actually he's Mr furlo he's the guy that
actually spent all that money and saved
our jobs when the going got tough and I
think labor know that actually there is
that sort of there is a there was a soft
spot for Richie sunac before he became
prime minister as Chancellor because of
how he handled himself during the
covered pandemic it's very easy to spend
money it's a lot harder to take it away
in tax Rises and spending cuts but I
wonder whether actually it's a little
bit more complex than just that idea
that he's aloof and out of touch and his
personal ratings are ticking up which is
why labor are going at him so hard yeah
we haven't got time to talk about the
attack ads no doubt we will another week
14 months you think it's going to be
June surely later in the year next year
anyway I don't know I wouldn't be so
sure I wouldn't be so sure if it's if
you know if if I was planning a general
election you know early next year I'd
tell everyone I thought it was October
as well but Jeremy Hunt let the cat out
of the bag a bit in in Washington last
week when he was asked that very
question about you know he said we
wouldn't go to the country until the
economy is looking good and I asked when
he thought the economy would be looking
good enough he said about this time next
year so by this time next year it's
we're going to know we're gonna be an
election fever either way well we'll get
Jessica's vote on that as well and also
your paper the guardian which has been
pushing hard about prepayment meters
with news of new guidelines to try to
keep these companies in check Jessica
yes and and these are new these new
guidelines that certainly I think a lot
of people tomorrow will be waking up and
saying that they don't go far enough so
this will be energy suppliers have
agreed that they will abide by a ban on
forcibly installing these very
controversial prepayment minters in the
homes of customers over 85
um and will also make uh Representatives
where where body cams so that the kind
of behavior we saw in the investigation
the times did
um you know will hopefully then be
picked up on on by the companies
um but those you know there was a huge
outcry you'll remember about the agents
using these kind of core these actually
call to proved entry warrants to break
in and install these
um in the homes of in sometimes very
vulnerable
um customers despite you know apparently
having to do a welfare visit before it's
installed and those those visits were
cursory to say the least um and I think
that there will be you know lots of
people who say that
um the plan the vulnerable people who
are who are younger than 85
um what does this mean for people with
disabilities what does this mean for
young families is there still going to
be these forced installations
um and and you know I think that there's
the government May well come under some
pressure
um for to make the regulator go further
than this and your bet for the election
next year I might keep a book
I think one of I I think that labor are
absolutely convinced it will be May next
year and one of the reasons they are is
because they think that uh the next
cycle of local elections is a
particularly difficult one for the
Tories and if there is if there is a
very very bad set of local election
results
um then going into an election in sort
of six months after that then things
could get very shaky for issue night
with his party I don't know if that
calculation is quite right but if you
did do a May election and you did a big
and the tourists did a big giveaway
budget in March that would really
squeeze the time labor would have in
order to make their own case
um without it the possibility of it
being stolen at that budget so I think I
think Harry's right I think there is
there's certainly an argument for for an
election in May
um the Countess of that is of course why
would you be prime minister for for 18
months when you could potentially be a
prime minister for two years and deliver
more I mean that's that's the way she
counter argument but I do think I do
think it's possible for a spring one
next year absolutely well never mind
waiting until next year for the elect
for the economy to get better Daily
Express tells us there are reasons to be
cheerful now the economy is on the mend
Harry what's the evidence
um green shoots I'd say rather than the
economy going gangbusters but there is
uh consumer confidence appears to be up
uh growth forecasted being revised in
the right direction not we're not
thinking massive great stonking growth
but um growth nonetheless recession has
been dodged I mean on a technicality
really it's you're still we're sort of
bumbling along at zero grows in point
one and here and and point two there and
so there is a the sort of at least the
sort of benefit of not being in the in a
in a recession
um inflation predicted to to start it
has to be it predictions to be met it
had to start falling pretty soon
obviously there was a unexpected little
uptick in it um last month so just
generally all the sort of pointers uh
and all the market sort of uh analysts
who try to forecast all their stuff are
pretty bullish so
um as you say it feeds into that
Narrative of of when would you go to the
country uh I think it will build very
different uh political climate if
inflation really is as as as the obr
said last year going to be in sort of
back to where it should be at sort of
two percent next year I'll believe it
when I see it I think there is a um
there's a slight issue that I think
we're in um what one Economist described
to me and I can't say it on television
I've just realized but uh I haven't got
a solid economy uh where people actually
thinking times are pretty tough I've got
a bit of money I'm just going to spend
it anyway and you know to hell with the
consequences and and they're not saving
their spending now that sort of
artificially can keep our inflation
quite high that could be a problem
further down the line
um but so far you know this this month
there is a growing feeling that the sort
of worse is behind us as in the country
we're waiting to see the sort of data
bear that out but um again that again
would point to uh the stories perhaps
being an ability to not necessarily
choose when they go to the country but
have the options open to them that
actually they could go early and try and
secure but she's doing like a legacy of
his own um just let's go to the times
shall we yet another warning about the
threat from China who's this uh from
this time
yeah this is from Mindy Cameron who's
the head of the national cyber security
Center who's saying that the UK and its
allies cannot afford complacencies over
the dramatic rise of China as a
technology superpower and it's
essentially saying that there's no
desire to from Beijing to collaborate or
with uh or to or even to kind of reach
parity with with Western countries that
it's aiming for this kind of technical
Supremacy
um uh and that the the measure of
success will be the strength it uses to
sort of achieve a dominant role in in
global Affairs and basically is you know
essentially the message is that uh that
they can't afford to not to sort of keep
the UK can't afford another another kind
of Western Powers can't afford not to
try and keep Pace with Chinese
developments in uh on cyber security and
uh you know otherwise you know we could
could be chronically Left Behind is one
of the a number of kind of warnings that
have come out about
um you know developments in China the
the way that is seeking to to dominate
this this sphere
um over the coming over the past few
months and many people asking when you
talk about this how we become less
economically reliant on China why can't
we produce the bits that they produce
that our Industries need Harry and you
know we've seen that recently with the
uh with the failure of that battery
company that it's not it's not so easy
yeah but we're playing catch up for um
for essentially what has been a you know
probably one of the most serious foreign
policy uh cock-ups and sewers since Iraq
for sure certainly and the fact that you
know we're paying sort of 15 20 year
catch up on the fact that you know since
the late 90s
um and through the naughties and uh and
uh into this conservative government you
you were you saw a sort of over Reliance
on China we it wasn't long ago that
George Osborne was cow Towing to to
Beijing we'll talk of a new golden era
now nicknamed in white and all the
Golden Era
um because we have been left ourselves
completely susceptible we're playing
sort of catch-ups with the Americans as
well and who can who have been trying to
sound the alarm on this for a long time
I think covid actually
um really did speed up the sort of
reality check for for the West in the
the what they're dealing with in China
this is a country that lied
um and obstacated and still lying about
the out the origins of of an outbreak
that's killed billions of people around
the world so it's good to see the
National Security apparatus kicking in
but it's a shame it didn't happen 10
years ago
um this is all sort of feeding down from
the recently updated integrated review
Into the sort of strategic threats faced
by Britain that's where the sort of
ministers sort of set the uh set the
sort of direction of travel and then
you'll start to see
um the sort of Security Services like
the national cyber security agency which
is an offshoot of gchq you'll see MI5
and MI6 I imagine making similar noises
in the coming months but Britain stopped
short of calling China a strategic
threat you know our our biggest hostile
sort of state-based threat they set the
stop slightly short of that but she
still like said it when he was
campaigning to be prime minister but
won't say it as prime minister so you
can see them they're going quite far on
this but I still say I still think and I
suspect lots of MPS will still think
that Britain could be going harder and
firmer and and tougher on China but they
don't seem to be willing to do so yeah
so I'll just speed you up
um just to want to get to the Delhi
Telegraph uh Jessica uh Single Sex
schools will not be forced to
accommodate transgender pupils these are
Under government guidelines um expected
to be issued within weeks
yeah the telegraphs seem to have seen
these um these guidance on how to treat
uh trans pupils which was promised at
the beginning of the summer term which
has obviously started this week
um and it's come after lots of
um criticisms about the way that schools
have handled uh trans people's
um whether you know people peoples who
are in Single Sex schools uh would be
able to transition while they're there
and this would give Single Sex schools
the right to refuse to admit pupils of
the other legal sex which otherwise
um you know might have been seen as a
breach of the equality act if they'd if
they did so and it will also I think
with something again which will will be
controversial to to to a lot of sort of
young campaigners on this issue that
teachers won't
um have any requirement to call children
by the preferred pronouns that they that
they would like to be um identified with
um and and it's being it's a sort of
joint project between did and Keegan the
education secretary and the and and the
equalities and and Minister Kelly
badanoch who's made it really clear that
she's quite interested in the idea of
even changing sections of the equalities
actor to give some
um special definitions around around
biological
um sex
um as well as just you know as well as
gender so I think you know again this is
um the conservative sort of Leaning into
uh this this fight which has you know
have not particularly edifying
um uh language around it on on on all
sides frankly sorry we're running out of
time you didn't choose the coronation
quiche either replace with spinach broad
beans and fresh tarragon talk about that
soon no doubt uh both of you thank you
very much Jessica L got Lego got it on
Jessica elgot and Harry Cole thank you
both very much